i keep saying we because we're we're
like we're like one unit so all by
myself and haitian's podcast co-host
heather duffy is still processing the
death of her late friend heather broke
her silence on wednesday and shared a
heartfelt tribute remembering the
actress's impact on her life and others
she opened up on their joint instagram
to express what she calls a profound
loss
adding ann was joyful despite all the
challenges that she faced in her life
she was truthful despite being in a
business that is make-believe
you never know what's going to be put in
front of you it's very different life
and people don't understand it we don't
talk about it very much the two appeared
thickest thieves on their better
together podcast
[Music]
right on sister right on sister they had
candid conversations with guests and
experts about their stories stumbles and
triumphs while celebrating friendship
earlier in the week their podcast
producer also pinned an emotional post
writing we lost someone irreplaceable i
appreciate
heather and
and ryan for for for being here for me
when i'm not back in 2020 anne proudly
told et about their mission for the show
heather duffy who i'm doing my podcast
better together with
we are people who live in our knowledge
and and our self-knowledge is one thing
but everyone else's is is everything and
that's what we want to share and build
community of harmony and harmony is what
heather says and was all about in her
post she made a point to honor anne's
contributions to the lgbtqia plus
community specifically how she handled
criticism of her relationship with ellen
degeneres
quote so many do not know the bravery
and the sacrifice it took for anne to
stand up for the right to love who you
wanted back in the late 90s a lot of
people were commenting like and to just
get over ellen it's actually not about
ellen it's about the stand that you took
at that time and the effect that it had
on your career and now
what you stood up for that was
so you were vilified for now
is being celebrated by everybody and
that the reason it's being celebrated is
because people like you took a stand
of course anne famously brought then
girlfriend ellen to the volcano movie
premiere in 1997 and received public
backlash for putting their romance on
display she deserves everything in the
world it was a moment heather says ann
helped move the needle for many quote we
have come a long way because of her
truth bravery and kindness in that
moment 25 years ago love is a choice
and i made one and it was one of the
most life-changing choices of my life
and i stand up for that more than i
would i would do the same thing all over
again
over the years anne continued to stand
up for what she believed in even writing
her 2001 memoir call me crazy discussing
her mental health struggles from being
in the limelight and her past high
profile relationship with ellen one
every time you tell the truth you're
going to have a 50 50 shot of people
wanting you to tell the truth and people
wanting you to shut up which has been
kind of the pattern of my life that same
year anne went on to build a family of
her own she married ex-husband coleman
lefone and they later welcomed son homer
in 2002.
after ann was taken off life support and
pronounced dead last week coleman posted
an emotional tribute
she had a lot to say she was brave and
fearless loved really hard
and was never afraid to let us know what
she think and what she believed in and
it was always love it was all about love
goodbye anne
love you thank you thank you for all the
good times there were so many
and
see you on the other side and in the
meantime i got our son and he'll be fine
love you
you